So with the new IT movie coming out in just
a couple day, I figured I better do that video
I promised where I answer your IT questions.
Cynder is out of town right now, so it's just
gonna be me answering the questions, but I'm
feeling pretty confident that I can give you
guys a satisfying answer.
The first question comes from Chloe Froud.
She asks, "Do you think IT will take the shape
of the other forms that weren't shown in the
mini series such as Jaws?"
That's a good question Chloe.
Yes, I do think that we'll see it take other
forms, but I'm not so sure about Jaws.
I talked about this a little bit in my Ideas
for IT at Halloween Horror Nights, check that
video out here if you haven't seen it, and
basically what I said is that in the book
and the miniseries which take place in the
50s, IT takes the form of some of the movie
monsters from back then: the most notable
one being Richie having an encounter with
the Wolfman after going to see The Wolfman
film in theaters and being afraid of it because
it is constantly praying on the fears of its
victims so my idea was that instead of using
classic 50's horror icons is that this movie
would you use classic 80s for icons like Freddy,
Jason, Chucky and Michael Myers.
So to answer the part of your question about
Jaws, I doubt that we'll see Jaws in this
movie, because that movie came out in 1975,
so it'd be more applicable to if this what
movie was taking place in the 70s as opposed
to the 80s.
Yes, it was still relevant in the 80s, but
I just don't see a spot for Jaws to really
appear in Derry.
The only major body of water is the Kenduskeag
stream, and I think it would be a little bit
silly for a shark to appear out of a stream.
It could happen but I think it's more likely
that we'll see horror icons from the 80s in
this film.
Next question comes from Angelo Zarola.
"Are all of Pennywise's red balloons the dead
children that he's eaten?"
Well, if you look at it in a literal sense,
no, there is a separate physical manifestation
of the dead children which appears at the
end of the story, which I'm not going to spoil
right now, for those who haven't seen the
movie.
But in a more symbolic sense, I would say
yes, they do represent the dead children,
which is why Pennywise is always using the
line, "you'll float too," or "you'll float
down here," because each of Pennywise's victims
does float, again I don't want to give it
away, and I think the red balloons are kind
of a physical manifestation of that in the
real world.
So yes, the balloons do kind of represent
his victims.
Gavin K asks our next question, "will the
IT movie be in two parts?"
Yes, it will.
So the movie was originally supposed to come
out as IT: Part 1 - The Loser's Club, and
then at some point they simplified the title
to just "IT".
But it is still going to be a 2-parter like
the miniseries was with the child portion
taking place first and the adult portion taking
place in Part 2.
I think that the main difference between this
movie and the mini-series, is that in the
mini-series it kind of sticks to the formula
laid out by the book, where it actually starts
with the Lucky 7 as adults being called back
to their home town to face IT again based
on the promise that they made years ago.
As each one of them is called back, they remember
what happened to them in Derry, and they have
these flashbacks to their encounters with
Pennywise as children.
So it has kind of a nonlinear story structure,
where it takes place in the present but it
has these flashbacks to their childhood memories
in the past and we see how things unfolded.
My prediction is that this new movie is not
going to do that and it's just gonna tell
the story in a linear fashion with the beginning
starting at the very beginning of the child
portion and Part 1 stretching until that promise
is made.
And then Part 2 will just include their lives
as adults and not include those flashbacks
to their childhood.
Matty Plays asks, "doesn't IT live in the
sewers?", and that's a response to the video
that I did showing the IT Neibolt House and
the hashtag #thatswhereitlives basically implying
that IT lives in 29 Neibolt.
In the book, yes, it does live in the sewers.
I think the best way for me to explain this
is that the 29 Neibolt House is like IT's
HQ up on the surface, whereas it's true home
is down in the sewers.
We also see in the trailer and the IT experience
itself, which if you want to check out that
video, here is the link, that 29 Neibolt seems
to be connected to the sewers and there's
a scene where they use a projector to line
up the map of the sewers to the map of Derry
and basically show that the sewer lines run
right under the 29 Neibolt House.
There's a scene in the book where they actually
venture into 29 Neibolt and confront Pennywise
and Pennywise actually retreats from there
down into the sewers, where they eventually
go to have their final confrontation with
him.
So I would expect something similar here.
Neazyy Squad asks, "Do you think that this
movie will be better than the TV series??
Or will it be bad and horrible?"
Him of course referring to the 1990 TV mini-series
starring Tim Curry.
I have high hopes for this movie.
I think with each trailer that's come out
I've gotten more excited for it.
I've talked to a couple people who have seen
the film and heard nothing but positive things
so far.
So I'm not really expecting a disappointment.
Do I think it will be better than the TV mini-series?
Well, I think there's definitely a chance
for it to be.
The mini-series, in my opinion, is very good.
I think this movie is going to do a lot of
things that the mini-series just was not able
to.
I've talked about this a little bit in Things
You Missed, but one example is the inclusion
of Patrick Hockstetter, who I'll just say
is a character who does some extremely dark
things in the book that couldn't be included
in the mini-series.
And I've heard that this new movie will just
go to those darker places; go to those more
extreme lengths.
And this is one of many examples in the book
of just how dysfunctional this town of Derry
is.
How all of the adults seem to be willing to
turn a blind eye to the horrible things that
are happening to these kids, and I hope that
we can see more of that in this new movie.
Now, will it live up to what we were given
with the mini-series?
Again, I think it will be different, but I'm
hoping with the increased budget and R-rating,
that it will live up to what we were given
in 1990 and maybe even surpass it.
And another thing is that Part 2 will be very
interesting because the best part of the mini-series
is the child portion.
And there're still a lot of things that I
like about the adult portion, the very ending
not being one of them.
But if you ask pretty much anyone what their
favorite part was, they're probably going
to say Part 1, so what I'm most interested
to see is how Part 2 is going to compare to
Part 2 of the mini-series.
I'm hoping that they might take it in a different
direction and hopefully include the thing
that happens after the ending of the mini-series
that happens in the book.
If you guys have read the book you know what
I'm talking about.
OK, next we're gonna get into some spoiler
questions so if you haven't read the book,
I recommend clicking away or pausing this
video and reading the book...
It's a long book.
Mineblox20 says, "I think they'll have a spot
where they show "IT" as the spider creature.
What do you think?
Well, I think it's pretty unlikely that we'll
see that in this film.
I think if they do decide to go with the spider
again that it will be in Part 2.
So, do I think that it will be in Part 2?
Yes, I think that we'll see it, but I think
they may shift away from that being like the
final boss kind of thing.
It's something that works a little bit better
on paper, but I think it's just more fitting
for the clown that terrorized them through
the entire thing to be the final boss as opposed
to this spider which kind of comes out of
nowhere.
I do understand the reasoning for the spider,
because the Lucky 7, or what's left of them,
come together and IT is unable to find something
that they're all afraid of, and this is really
like the best form that it can manifest to
face all of them at once.
But, with that being said, you want the end
of the movie to be the climax, the scariest
part, so I don't think that having a spider
is really the best option.
And this is also something that's touched
on in the book, I forget who it was, but somebody's
thinking that a spider is something that you
might see crawling around in your kitchen,
something that you experience in real life,
whereas killer clowns are not, so that makes
it a lot easier for them to face.
I would like to see the Spider form come up
at some point during that confrontation in
Part 2, but I don't think that it should be
the final boss.
Another clue towards the possible inclusion
of the spider, again, I've talked about this
before, but...
The Dark Tower movie.
It may or may not have tie-ins with this IT
movie, I know they're made by different studios,
but there are a lot of Stephen King references
in The Dark Tower movie, one of which being
when they're at an abandoned amusement park
and they're sitting by the fire talking about
the monsters that live in this outer realm
that surrounds their central universe.
I forget what the exact terms for it are but
you're gonna have to bear with me on that.
So he draws in the sand.
He shows their center universe and he shows
the creatures that are trying to get in from
outside and the creature that's used as an
example is tarantula, which crawls into the
barrier and comes to where they are.
So if the movies are connected, that could
be some kind of foreshadowing for the fact
that the spider creature will appear again.
Sammy Saldana, "Do you know if Richie will
die because in the trailer it showed something
like that?"
In book and in the mini-series Richie does
not die, he is one of the survivors and I
can't really see them killing him off in this
one.
Like I said, I think the only two major differences
are gonna be the fact that this takes place
in the 80s rather than the 50s and the non-linear
story structure being shifted into a more
linear one just focusing on the kids in Part
1.
In any event, in this first movie I can't
really see any of the kids dying.
We even see in the trailer the scene of the
promise and they all seem to be present for
that.
So I think everybody at least makes it on
to Part 2.
Blitzon Benth asks, "Do you think Pennywise
will reveal his true form?"
And there were a lot of questions about this
asking, "Do you think that we'll see the spider?"
"Do you think we'll see the true form?"
And in my mind this is just a little bit different
than the question about the spider because
he could be referring to The Deadlights as
Pennywise's true form, not the spider.
And of course it's gonna depend how you interpret
it, but I see The Deadlights as the true form
of IT, whereas Pennywise and the spider are
just different manifestations, including some
of the other ones that I talked about.
So do I think that The Deadlights are gonna
be in this movie?
We haven't really seen any evidence of it
in the trailer, but there is this one shot
of Beverly being lifted up off of the ground,
which could also tie in to phrase, "you'll
float too," and there seems to be some kind
of light shining on her, so I think that could
be the work of The Deadlights.
I do think we'll see The Deadlights make a
return in this adaptation.
So that just about covers the questions you
guys asked on Twitter.
I'm gonna be seeing this movie as early as
possible and get cooking on hopefully a new
episode of Things You Missed, so be on the
lookout for that.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that death-bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.